there is a very sick woman in Arizona
now not Kerry Lake not Kerry Lake I'm
talking about state senator Wendy Rogers
State Senator Wendy Rogers 48 hours ago
said Kerry Lake might still be instated
the governor of Arizona now I want you
to answer honestly really tell me
do you believe Wendy Rogers believes any
of what she's saying or does she have to
keep saying this stuff because she
started saying it and it would be
embarrassing to her to have to admit
that she was wrong take a listen to what
she had to say remember Carrie Lake ran
for governor in Arizona she lost in that
her opponent Katie Hobbs got more votes
Katie Hobbs is now the governor of
Arizona even if for whatever reason
Katie Hobbs resigned or died or whatever
uh it would actually be the Secretary of
State of Arizona that becomes Governor
Arizona doesn't currently have a
position lieutenant governor although
they are creating it starting in a
couple of years but here is what Wendy
Rogers said and I get asked this all the
time especially do you my district on
various uh rural radio stations Senator
Rogers the the radio stations must be so
rural that the people don't understand
how government works you represent four
other counties other than Maricopa
County what hope do you have of getting
any of this legislation passed and my
answer is twofold number one I was voted
in by 27 percentage points to do the
very thing that I'm doing which is
represent my constituents and make sure
that my voters were not disenfranchised
and number two they weren't
you never know uh everything that will
happen in terms of Kerry Lake being
instated as governor and I get asked
this
yeah also I'm waiting to see if maybe
the Eagles actually won the Super Bowl
on Sunday you never know you know what I
mean in a couple months or maybe in a
year
um it we might learn that it was
actually the Eagles who won which is
really really wild my uh my headphone
has just popped out of my ear and it's
going to be hard to hear the following
clip if I don't put it back in there we
go
um so
do you think she believes this do you
think Wendy Rogers believes this or do
you think it's part of the Griff now
here's a reminder the very same Wendy
Rogers a couple months ago or when was
it December I guess uh December she
claimed that Carrie Lake was the
governor-elect of Arizona she wasn't and
we had the same question then does she
believe this the problem and uh we need
to get to the bottom of all of this and
I just telling you we're not having it
anymore we're done as Kerry said
as Kerry said you're messing with the
wrong people
[Music]
right
Carrie Lake the governor elect of
Arizona yes
is there any doubt in your mind
okay so just so you know there's no
lieutenant governor in Arizona the
secretary of state is next in line if
anything should happen to the governor
death resignation impeachment whatever
starting in 2027 the lieutenant governor
is going to become the would become the
governor upon the death resignation or
removal from Office of the governor of
Arizona and then uh it would presumably
go to the Secretary of State so who
thinks that Wendy Rogers genuinely
believes
at any moment you might see the in
statement of Kerry Lake as governor of
Arizona and who believes that Wendy
Rogers knows she's lying but this is
just the nonsense that she feels she has
to say for whatever reason let me know
in a YouTube comment send an email to
info davidpackman.com send a smoke
signal telegram however you want to get
in touch I'm curious what you think I
genuinely don't know I lean towards
Wendy Rogers knows this isn't true
there's no possibility of instating
Kerry Lake but Maybe I'm Wrong